Okay, let's walk you through the vision prompting guide, which is how to prompt a vision model
and just really showing you what they're capable of doing. So vision models, typically called
multimodal models, that means they have multiple modes of input, not just text, but you can
input images as well. And I'm sure there's going to be more coming in terms of inputting
video and inputting audio, etc. So one of the big breakthroughs, I think, in recent years
is that chat GPT can see now. So up to AI, they released a few months ago at the developer
conference at the end of 2023. And now it's pretty easy to have AI look at an image and
tell you what's in it. Back in 2014, it was so impossible to do that, that there was a
joke on the internet on XKCD that if you needed to take a picture and see if the
picture contained a bird, it would be like a five-year research project with a team of
PhDs. So it was virtually impossible. Whereas now, it's pretty easy, you just ask chat GPT.
Which multimodal models are available as well as chat GPT, which uses GPT-4 vision. There's
also CLIP by OpenAI as an open source model that was released as part of Stable. It's
actually what Stable Diffusion was originally built on. It's a very simple model, though
it can only really tell you what's in an image or give you captions of an image. Gemini 1.5
Pro by Google is multimodal. It also accepts video, which is really cool. Cloud3 by Anthropic
now accepts images too. And then there's a couple of other open source alternatives.
So Lava 1.6 by Meta is open source. That is a fine tune of the Llama 2 model. So it accepts
images as well as text. And then there's also Quinn VL, which is by Alibaba. So what can
it do? Here's an example that really blew my mind. I uploaded an image of a Twitch stream
of the game World of Tanks. And it could pull out lots of information. It could detect
different objects. Is there a tank in this image? It can read text from the image as well.
It can understand overall layout and UI. It can give feedback on that if you are prompting
it for that reason. It can also understand what's happening. It can explain what's happening
in the scene based on that image, which is really exciting.
What I'm going to do now is apply the five principles of prompting to vision prompting.
Because what you'll see is it doesn't matter what the AI model is. Essentially, there's
always these same five principles that apply. So everything you've learned for text and
image prompting will also work for vision as well.
First principle was give direction. And that's also true here. People have found that by
pointing to specific objects and literally annotating an image, like drawing a circle
around the thing that you want to ask about, that works really well. And you can combine
that with traditional ML and image segmentation techniques. So you can draw these on programmatically.
Identify if there's a bottle in the image, draw an arrow next to the bottle programmatically,
and then query GPT Vision to ask your question about that bottle.
Specifying format also works. JSON mode works here as well, which is really great. You
can get structured text from an image. So here's an example of reading a driver's license
and pulling out the important information. That's really exciting.
There's also the concept of providing examples. It can actually accept multiple images. It
just doesn't need to be just one. And it's in the chat format, just like any other kind
of chat that you have with chat GPT. Here's an example where they got it to correctly read
a speedometer, which is something it fails at, where they just provided a few examples
first. The first two images, they manually wrote the response. And then the third one,
they just included the image and then GPT-4 was able to write that response there and
get it correct, which is really good. Evaluating quality is just as important with
vision as it is with any other LLM work that you're doing, because it sometimes gets things
wrong. So it does a pretty good of recognising who these people are. They're famous researchers.
But the bounding boxes it draws around them are a little bit off. You can see it's
missed and GNG or engineering here with the bounding box. I don't fully trust it for
every task. You need to evaluate quality just like you do for anything.
Division of labour works here as well. So if you divide a task up into multiple prompts,
or even within the same prompt, if you get to think step by step by prompting it to figure
out let's count these apples row by row, does a much better job of getting the exact correct
response. And you can see here where we didn't ask it to do that, it didn't count the right
number of apples. Cool. Now I think the biggest thing, the most exciting thing for me is
temporal reasoning. What I mean by that is it can actually understand what's happening in a
sequence of images. Here's an example where she showed four pictures of someone doing a push up,
they go down, and then they go up again. And you can actually ask it, what's this person going
to do next? They're going to do a push up. It actually understands the sequence of images here,
and it could reorder the images as well if you put them out of sequence, which is, again,
very exciting. Now this is really different. I think this is the thing that you couldn't do
before with traditional ML because they didn't have a reasoning engine behind it. You could
identify that there are cameras in the image, you could identify a person in the image,
but it couldn't really figure out what that person is doing from frame to frame. And I think that
little glimpse of intelligence, that is really what makes this very special and worth the
absorbent cost comes with using vision models. I applied this to a project that I worked on
recently where we transcribed the audio for some video, but we also transcribed the images
using AI Vision. So we got it to provide commentary on the game, and this is from a Twitch stream.
So you can see the sequence of images we provided, these are the timestamps in seconds,
and then this is the commentary here that the AI wrote, and it's really good. You can
stitch all this together as well. One of the things that we found is that it can handle
maybe up to 30 images at the minute in terms of the context length, and it's also very expensive.
So it turned out to be about $6 an hour to do this, which isn't actually that far off
paying someone in a low cost country to do it. We expect that's going to come down by an order
of magnitude soon. One thing you have to watch out is AI models have a mind of their own to
come be trusted. Just like I said before, evaluation is really important. We found that
quite often, it would refuse to do the request or get things wrong. So we had to really develop
a lot of good evaluation techniques in order to make sure this is working. And it's a real pain,
because every time we get something wrong, that's costing you real money for a vision request. It
could be a couple of cents each. So if you're doing hundreds of hours of footage, then these
problems really add up. So we developed a bunch of evaluation metrics. A few different things that we
found were useful is we had a test set where we actually knew the answers. So we could provide a
sequence, and then we knew what sorts of things were in that sequence. And we asked it to identify
whether those things were in the sequence. And what we can do then is get an accuracy score.
So we can see how often did it predict false, and it actually was false. How often did it
predict false, but it actually was true. One of the things we found is that it doesn't hallucinate
when something isn't there. So it actually had zero cases where, let's give an example.
Is there a tank in this image? It doesn't imagine there's a tank in the image if it's not there,
but sometimes it would miss something. One of the things we're looking for was close quarters
combat. And sometimes there was actually close quarters combat, and it didn't recognize that.
So the accuracy was about 80% for the things that we were testing out.
The other thing we needed to do was figure out how close it got with some labeling. It wouldn't
always label the same things the same way. We had active combat as one of the labels here,
but then sometimes it would come up with a new label, which is active combat engagement,
which is so close that it's pretty much the same thing. And we would treat that as a winning test
answer. This was the reference answer, and then this is what it came up with. And because it's
so close, we used cosine similarity on a vector database. We're based just based on this text
that we could get that similarity back. We count it as a one if the similarity was above 90%.
And you can see some examples where that is. One thing we expect is that open source models
will bring down cost. So this is an experiment I ran with 1.6, and it's a 30 billion parameter
model. It does a pretty good job. It's slow, though. At the present, it takes about five
minutes to process one minute worth of video, which isn't great. It's much slower than real
time. GPT Vision is actually slightly faster than real time. This obviously will speed up.
This was me running it on my three MacBooks. Over time, I expect the speed will increase,
the cost will come down, and be relatively cheap to sequence any sort of video.
One of the really exciting things I've seen, which I think will change a lot,
and it's not something I really predicted, was using this for software development.
TLDraw did a really cool feature in the platform where you can take your mockup,
and then it takes a screenshot of that mockup, and it feeds it to GPT Vision.
Then what you get back is a generated code. It literally generates the design, the code,
for you based on that mockup. You just click make it real, which is pretty cool.
So there's going to be all sorts of new modalities there. I think now that AI can see,
then maybe typing text into a box isn't going to be the main way we interact with AI,
but we'll see. One of the other exciting things I found is that, especially with Google,
I'm seeing some demos here that it can return structured data from video.
Here is an example of some of the works at Google. They uploaded a video of American Cars,
and then it pulled out structured data of what cars are in the video. I think this is going to be
really big importance, especially because Google's model has 1 million token context windows. So you
could potentially take a whole movie and pull out structured data of which characters appeared
and which parts of the movie. That could open up quite a bit. That's the sort of stuff that
people like Netflix pay millions of dollars for people to do manually right now, which should
hopefully be done by AI in the future for a lot less money. So what are the other Vision
use cases? I just listed a few here that I came up with. This is primarily from a paper
I'll enter at the end, but a few that are interesting. It's pretty good at understanding
medical images, although it's not a doctor's. They can at least help you diagnose what's going
on potentially. They can recognize logos, it can count objects, it can tell you what's funny
about an image. It's also good at visual reasoning, so it can infer from visual clues in the image
what's going on. It can extract text, it's really good at code architecture. Not just
the example I showed you where we draw a mock-up and it turns that into front-end code,
but also in the back-end. You can draw a mock-up of a data architecture or a database structure
and it can turn that into Python code. It can interpret charts, it can actually pull data from
the chart, so extract all the sales figures from this pie chart could be really interesting.
It can translate language, which is really powerful, especially when it gets faster than
real time. You'll be able to hold it up just like you can do with Google Translate right now.
You can hold it up to a sign and it can automatically translate that back into your native
language. It's really good at data extraction as well. You can pull data out the image,
like you've seen examples of, to read human emotions and understand them and infer information
from them. It can evaluate aesthetics, so I've seen some people use this in image prompting.
It can evaluate whether something is beautiful or not. It can score it, which is pretty cool.
It can detect defects. I imagine this can be used a lot in factories in order to identify
whether something has gone wrong or the product has got a hole in it or something needs to be
stopped about the manufacturing process. Then the final two, I think, is where it really gets sci-fi
embodied agents. Being able to walk around as a robot and it can actually tell you
where to go to get something from the fridge. That means it can actually be applied to a robot
and that robot can then use deep division to understand where it's moving in the world.
I think that's pretty cool. You can also set up a browsing agent, so a little bit less sci-fi than a
robot walking around your home, but you can get it to actually operate your browser, operate your
computer, and book things for you or schedule things for you. I think that's going to be
really powerful as well. If you wanted to learn a little bit more about visual prompting,
I really recommend this paper. It's where a lot of these examples came from. It's called The Dawn of
LMMs. That's L-M, Large Multimodal Models instead of L-L-M, Large Language Models. But yeah,
I think this is the future. I think there's a lot of unexpected businesses that are going to come
out of this that will prove to be really impactful on our world. The quicker you can test out this
stuff, the better.